salut je suis tombé dans l'eau comme en
2007 vous avez vu oui parce que c'est
une vidéo qui me rappelle un peu les
mentale fixe de 2016 quand je vous
donnais une astuce de mémoire un truc
comme ça et aujourd'hui je te donne mes
cinq meilleures astuces en calcul mental
je vais essayer de pas faire trop long
c'est une astuce dont j'aie jamais parlé
sur la chaîne à ma connaissance est pas
très connus j'en ai pas parlé non plus
dans mon livre sur la mémoire parce que
à membres données on peut pas tout
mettre et pourtant je pense que ça peut
vraiment vous servir c'est extrêmement
utile moi ça me faire même pour les
vidéos c'est la méthode de richard
feynman qui est un professeur américain
qui renseignent des trucs très dur cet
animal est considéré aujourd'hui comme
l'un des professeurs les plus brillants
de son histoire et les plus forts pour
transmettre à savoir alors qu'il
enseigne la mécanique quantique se
passait pas spontanément tu ne dis pas
ça va être un truc facile à comprendre
la mécanique quantique et bell lui la
trouvais ça m'étonne et elle est
vraiment très détaillée je vous la donne
et maintenant pour mémoriser pas
forcément pour apprendre quelque chose à
quelqu'un mais pour mémoriser soi même
c'est le meilleur outil de contrôle pour
apprendre vite et apprendre efficacement
et vérifier l'état des connaissances
indie games and c'est l'un des
physiciens les plus éminentes son époque
l'enseigne et il apprend la mécanique
quantique mais sa méthode elle
s'applique à tous les concepts et elle
tient en quatre étapes la technique
globalement elle consiste à être capable
d'apprendre ce qu'on a à prendre nous
mêmes à un enfant de 8 ans à 10 ans si
vous êtes capable de l'enseigné un
enfant de 8 à 10 ans et qu'ils
comprennent c'est que vous avez tout
compris mémoriser et que vous maîtrisez
votre sujet première étape vous prenez
une feuille et un crayon c'est très
important de le faire avec du papier et
un crayon ou plusieurs crayon mais pas
avec un ordinateur ou un truc comme ça
pour déjà commencé à faire travailler un
peu le côté kinesthésique parce qu'on va
exploiter un peu tous les domaines de la
mémoire étape numéro 2 vous identifier
le sujet évidemment et vous noté sur
cette feuille tout ce que vous savez sur
ce sujet vous vous limitez pas vous
mettez tout ce que vous pouvez et vous
rajouterez d'ailleurs sur cette feuille
là au fur et à mesure les nouvelles
connaissances que vous arrivez à choper
à droite à gauche que vous continuez
peut-être à apprendre mais vous notez
tout vous devez avoir sur cette feuille
un état complet de vos connaissances sur
le sujet étape 3 vous allez expliquer
maintenant toutes ces notions comme si
vous parliez un petit enfant mais
vraiment c'est à dire que au delà même
de devoir l'expliquer à quelqu'un vous
devez capable de l'expliquer à un enfant
je ne sais pas pourquoi l'enfant est là
mais dans ma tête l'enfant est là il est
derrière il était plutôt sage depuis le
début de la vidéo donc vous devez re
noter tout ce que vous savez sur le
sujet mais d'une manière simple clair
avec des mots simples des mots très
facile à comprendre pour ça va falloir
utiliser des métaphores va falloir
utiliser énormément d'exemple des
exemples de la vie courante des choses
qui sont très accessibles en fait pour
tout le monde les enfants ne connaissent
pas le jargon ou vocabulaire complexe et
si vous cherchez à prendre par exemple
quelque chose de scientifique c'est
bourré de mots complexes et bien il va
falloir réussir à les détourner ça
marche évidemment pour faire des choses
à l'écrit ça marche aussi par exemple
pour pour des schémas pour des
graphiques des choses comme ça les
graphiques de fame and ils sont encore
utilisés aujourd'hui les autres
scientifiques ils s'en servent parce que
les gens comprennent instantanément des
choses qui n'arrivait pas avant feyman a
expliqué dans les grands cours
magistraux qui était long fastidieux et
personne piquée que dalle et pourquoi ça
intéressant pour vous pour moi quand on
ne peut pas utiliser de jargon on peut
pas se cacher derrière des connaissances
qu'on n'a pas par exemple j'ai utilisé
en début de vidéo le mot kinesthésique
mais si je devais utiliser un autre mot
est ce que je serais capable si je
devais pas passer par le mot
kinesthésique eh bien oui je suis
capable de l'expliquer je pourrais dire
on va utiliser un sens un petit peu
comme la vue qui a un sens c'est bien ça
va être le sens du toucher le sens du
toucher c'est la surface si c'est tout
doux par exemple comme un tapis si c'est
rugueux comme une écorce et de bois ou
si c'est chaud ou si c'est froid ces
salles kinesthésique mais j'aurais pu
très bien l'utiliser à la bonne place
sans bien savoir ce que ça voulait dire
et bien là avec cette méthode on n'y
coupe pas s'il ya un moquez pas maîtrisé
on va le sentir tout de suite il faut
être clair mais il faut être conscient
aussi il faut pas trop s'étaler donc
vous remettez tout votre état de
connaissances mais sans tout tiré en
longueur dites-vous que comme vous êtes
en train d'expliquer à l'enfant la
langue il abat cet enfant là comme c'est
un enfant il a pas une attention limitée
donc il va falloir que ce soit un peu
dynamique un peu rapide et que ça traîne
pas en longueur pour rien dire
évidemment si vous avez du mal à
formuler et à réaliser vos idées sur sur
les notions que vous connaissez sur le
sujet si vous avez du mal à les
retranscrire avec cette méthode là c'est
qu'il ya des lacunes quelque part ça
nous amène à la 4e étape 4e étape vous
identifiez vos lacunes qu'est-ce que
vous avez du mal à reformuler qu'est-ce
que vous avez du mal à expliquer qu
est-ce qui vous échappe qu'est ce que
vous ignorez là
anti fier tout ça et puis ma foi vous
allez sur internet dans les livres vous
aller combler maintenant vos lacunes ça
vous aura permis d'identifier les
endroits où vous avez une faiblesse de
connaissances même si vous pensiez avoir
vraiment bien compris dans le détail
donc vous vous partez en recherche à
prend un certain temps le temps que vous
voulez pour bat pour creuser le sujet et
pour le maîtriser vraiment à 360 degrés
c'est vraiment durant cette phase qui a
un vrai un vrai apprentissage un vrai
intérêt à faire cette méthode parce que
en plus le fait de rechercher par soi
même le fait d'identifier soi même ses
manques eh bien ça fait un meilleur
encodage et donc un meilleur stockage
dans la mémoire on arrive à la cinquième
et dernière étape je sais j'avais 10 4
parce que la cinquième pour moi c'est la
conclusion de tout ça c'est
l'application de la méthode vous allez
devoir organiser vos dernières notes
celles qui sont faites pour pour un
enfant les trier les organiser les
recommencer pour former une histoire
maintenant vous imaginez que c'est
vraiment l'histoire que vous que vous
allez proposer à l'enfant pour lui
raconter ce que vous avez besoin de lui
apprendre parce qu'encore une fois
l'étape 3 c'était juste de reformuler là
maintenant on arrive à la compilation de
tout ça n'oubliez pas une chose si vous
deviez expliquer ça à quelqu'un élire
vos notes à quelqu'un il faudrait que
qui est pas de prérequis en fait qu'il y
ait pas besoin d'un état de
connaissances avancées de la personne
sur le sujet que vous voulez traiter et
après pas c'est vraiment la phase de
test alors il ya plusieurs manières
détesté ça la première manière c'est de
le faire tout seul c'est à dire vous
parlais à voix haute comme si vous aviez
une classe devant vous ou quelqu'un qui
va vous interrogez pour un oral par
exemple ou un entretien d'embauché enfin
bon ce que vous voulez et vous lui
expliquez vous n'avez pas vos notes avec
vous vous pouvez pas regarder note vous
pouvez pas avoir tous et c'est qu'est ce
qui vous reste dans votre tête et vous
essayez de le faire évidemment vous
allez voir à quel moment vous butez les
endroits où vous avez du mal ces
endroits là ce sont des endroits à
retravailler ou faut aller re collecter
de l'information le réécrire voir
pourquoi vous n'allez pas le sortir
comme ça spontanément pour identifier
bien ça et se fait un bon feedback vous
pouvez l'enregistrer au dictaphone le
mieux c'est de le faire face à une
caméra comme je le fais vous posez votre
téléphone vous filmez et puis après vous
regarde
si vous étiez un examinateur par exemple
le jour d'un examen en train de prendre
des notes sur la personne et 10 rebonds
alors là il perd pied là on comprend pas
toutes les faiblesses que vous allez
identifier ces les endroits où fort au
travail et puis évidemment vous pouvez
les prouver sur quelqu'un ça c'est un
truc est formidable vous vous racontez
vous expliquer à quelqu'un qui pourra
aussi vous poser des questions au fur à
mesure et vous verrez pied si la
personne elle a tout compris l'essence
de tout ça à la tête du conseil en élite
et évidemment tous les jargons comme
voulait dit allez allez oust plus
directe a les outils simples toujours ne
cherchez pas à faire des détours des
choses comme ça si vous êtes capable
d'expliquer quelque chose simplement un
enfant de 5 ans c'est que vous l'avez
compris vous l'avez mémorisées le fait
d'atteindre ce niveau de compréhension
en fait là plusieurs strates de niveau
de compréhension si vous arrivez à
atteindre celui ci c'est nécessairement
que vous avez tout compris tout
mémoriser et donc en faisant ce chemin
vous à les mémoriser beaucoup mieux une
astuce de mémoire j'espère que ça vous
plaise j'en ai une autre avoue donné que
j'ai utilisée pour moi l'a récemment
début juillet au tout début de l'été
parce que j'ai passé mon permis bateau
j'avais tout le tout le code va lyon
tout le code pour le permis bateau à
apprendre apprendre en quelques jours
jean do ou trois jours je crois que j'ai
une méthode depuis des années que j'ai
créée qui mélange le système de
répétition et se passer mais en deux
trois jours on peut pas faire un vrai
système détenir des flash cards qui ne
sont pas bref si ça vous tant que je
pourrai vous faire une vidéo aussi là
dessus un petit peu à la rentrée ça peut
vous servir cette année vous m'en parlez
dans les commentaires à qui évidemment
si vous voulez plein d'astuces de
mémoire je vous rappelle j'ai sorti ça
début mai il ya toutes les astuces de
mémoire comme ça à l'intérieur avec lui
pourquoi ça fonctionne dans le cerveau
ce qu'il faut faire pas faire le livre
que j'aurais aimé lire ya 25 ans je vous
mettrais bien dans la description mais
les dents le toutes les librairies
évidemment bref si cette vidéo vous a
plu da pensez à vous abonner à la chaîne
ou à vérifier que vous avez été des
abonnés par youtube ou un truc comme ça
prenez soin de vous rendez vous au plus
tard lundi prochain 18 heures à très
bientôt ciao ciao